a vantagem a gente falar um pouco sobre
como pensar dentro da caixa e discutiu
sobre um pouco o que é na verdade a
caixa trouxe alguns conceitos é de uma
apresentação que na verdade é muito
interessante para mim e foi colocada por
alguns professores que eu tive enquanto
estudava em columbia nos estados unidos
a criatividade se esconde dentro da
caixa e agora vou mostrar o porquê dando
alguns conceitos básicos e primeiro uma
premissa importante esse cara falou
william magnata esse ou da 3m que
contratem boas pessoas e as deixem em
paz
essa primeira premissa para você poder
ser inovador você precisa ter paz
você precisa ter seu espaço e por falar
em um espaço entre pais e e afins com a
gente é criar uma ideia positiva quando
a gente quer criar alguma idéia a
avassaladora
a gente costuma fazer brainstorm eu digo
pra vocês agora acabem com o brainstorm
acabe com essa idéia de colocar várias
pessoas inteligentes no mesmo espaço na
mesma sala para dar uma ideia
maravilhosa porque porque a primeira
premissa do bem storm é não pode haver
críticas e quando a gente dá idéia a
primeira coisa que a gente pensa é as
pessoas vão nos criticar e uma coisa
certa
assim como existem pessoas que nos amam
existem pessoas que nos rodeiam
é óbvio isso então às vezes quando estou
na sala querendo dar alguma ideia
europeu olha para o lado e penso nas
pessoas que vão colocar a famosa areia
no meu projeto e isso me deixa a quadra
então a idéia de brainstorm também vai
além
ou seja à medida que você não pode
criticar as ideias
as pessoas tendem a respeitar as suas
ideias e ela só passarem ser ideias
porque não há críticas não há pilares
cuidar possam não há uma realidade senão
a pilares se não há críticas e também
storm na verdade é um dos principais
vilão da inovação mas como é que se
tenha uma idéia eureka
como é que tem uma ideia que possa mudar
o mundo
a idade ideal que você queira por
incrível que pareça o melhor ambiente
para ter uma ideia fantástica é quando
nós estamos fazendo atividades que não
exigem coordenação de atividade cerebral
máxima ou seja lavando prato quando
vamos ao banheiro quando varremos uma
casa por exemplo
esses momentos são os momentos
automáticos
é quando o nosso cérebro não está
realmente 100% ativo então a gente pode
utilizar de uma outra maneira para que
possamos ter uma idéia fantástica por
exemplo quem nunca cantou no chuveiro
teve aquela idéia de eureka tomando mãe
esse cara por exemplo só queria tirar
self enquanto surfava negócio ele tem um
problema ele gosta de ir à self e que
ele inventou e limitou a go pro uma
câmera que permitirá céu fiz em qualquer
ambiente no mundo dentro fora da água e
afins
esse outro cara ele queria apenas que a
mesa comece dentro do carro dele e que
ele inventou a equipe ia ele criou a kia
e aí tem uma história triste são a
mostra recebeu uma carta dizendo que a
sua amada havia falecido
só que quando recebi essa carta ela já
estava inclusive enterrado
ele falou pra si mesmo eu não quero que
ninguém mais sofrer do mesmo mal e aí
ele inventou o telégrafo
essas três ideias sei como base
fundamental uma coisa importantíssima
elas cobriram uma necessidade ea
necessidade é a mãe da inovação
se você partir da premissa de que as
pessoas precisam para ter algo vocês
conseguem pensar no fluxo e nesse fluxo
geral a sua ideia
e aí veio a idéia fantástica a
necessidade é a mãe da inovação uma mãe
nos estados unidos teve a ideia
maravilhosa
qual o problema principal das mães de
adolescentes principalmente quando vão
para a balada eles não atendem o
telefone ele não retorna a ligação eles
não fazem nenhum contato e o que essa
mãe que ou ela criou um aplicativo
chamado ignoro
com esse aplicativo faz justamente
aquilo que toda mãe deseja obriga o
filho a entrar em contato com ela é faz
a ligação para o filho se o filho não
atender a ligação ele bloqueia o sistema
do celular e só libera quando ele
retorna a ligação praça mais a
necessidade é a mãe da inovação ou seja
inovação na verdade é uma solução com a
necessidade ficou bem claro mas como é
que você cria uma necessidade
eu peguei o que aquele que pra mim foi o
maior inovador da minha era steve jobs
ele falou uma coisa fantástica
se fosse pra salvar a vida de uma pessoa
você achar uma maneira de diminuir 10
segundos da tela de iniciação de um
computador
ele estava com o time dele de construção
do mec do macbook e todo mundo que usa
mac book até quem usa sabe que a tela de
iniciação quando você liga o computador
até iniciar é muito mais rápido em
qualquer outra máquina que steve jobs
chegou para o time dele que cuidava
exatamente dessa parte da construção e
falou e se você for salva a vida de
alguém você faria isso mais rápido ele
criou a necessidade da pessoa é preciso
que a necessidade para que essas
necessidades sejam resolvidas
a resolução dela é a inovação uma coisa
é importante ser dita
não é porque você cria o único que ela
tenha utilidade
são muitas coisas que são únicas são
inúteis a inovação não quer dizer algo
útil à esquerda não quer dizer que seja
algo único
quer dizer que seja algo útil à visão
tradicional que existe hoje da
criatividade são basicamente três ideias
sem estrutura nenhuma ou seja não pode
haver estrutura anterior
é uma ideia que não tem regras ou
padrões é pensar fora da caixa que nunca
que ouviu essa famosa frase precisa se
pensar fora da caixa para criar algo
inovador
quando falo isso pra mim quando alguém
pede para que eu pense fora da caixa e
disse pra mim que pensa fora da caixa é
assim que imagino esse cara
imaginando fora da caixa
eu sou totalmente ao contrário do que se
pense fora da caixa é porque porque mais
inovações acontecem quando a rede está
no nosso ambiente familiar na nossa casa
pensando dentro da caixa ea taxa aqui
refere se ao nosso ambiente ao nosso
meio e obviamente nosso cérebro foi
inventado criado inovado ué site em
inglês a sigla significa sistema área
que vende e quem mais ou menos uma
maneira com sistemática de criar
pensamentos e ela trouxe cinco template
cinco componentes a primeira template de
subtração quando menos se torna mais que
eu possa extrair subtrair de um produto
que já exista tirar algo desse produto
tornando muito mais inovador e aí tem um
exemplo dos headphones que eu posso
tirar desses headphones para tornar o
algo mais inovador ainda eu tirei a
cobertura das orelhas
eu tirei a capinha de cima que os
conecta e eu transformei em yerson muito
mais leve muito mais suave de utilizar e
agora quer que eu subtrairia subtrairia
do iphone o que o tiraria do iphone e
transformar em um produto que me dessem
milhões número no mercado
eles tiraram no mesmo esquema de
produção apenas a função de telefone
mesma escala de produção criou dois
produtos em um só com o mesmo custo
tirando a função de telefone eles
criaram o ipod touch
subtraindo a função de telefone
eles criaram um produto que vendeu mais
de 60 milhões de unidades no mundo
inteiro - na casa desse cidadão ainda
não chegou à inovação para ele a segunda
dividir para conquistar a divisão é
template onde você tem um produto ou
serviço e você divide
ele pra criar uma inovação e é quando
nasceu às impressoras com cada cor em
seu cartucho
antes o início era um cartucho só para
tudo depois dois cartuchos e aí não
funcionavam com um deles acabava
agora a divisão permitiram que os
cartuchos viessem cada um com sua cor
o responsável por alguns quilos a mais
em toda a população mundial
o controle remoto ele foi dividido para
a televisão
colocado em sua mão hoje ninguém precisa
mais levantar só vai perder calorias
mudando o canal
infelizmente a terceira tem play the
future' ficar para multiplicar
é a multiplicação que eu posso
multiplicado em um produto para que ele
se transforme em um outro produto em
algo inovador dentro do mercado que ele
já exista tv pela televisão 3d por
exemplo não é necessário você tem uma tv
que tenha uma terceira dimensão
multiplicou-se a função dela e trouxe
essa inovação para que nós pudéssemos
utilizar dentro da nossas próprias casas
e aí os brinquedos mais famosos na
bicicleta para a criança é criança não
tem um equilíbrio que o adulto tem então
multiplicou-se a bicicleta colocou se as
rodinhas nela e teve um produto criou se
um produto para criança dentro de um
produto a ideia que era feita pra adulta
quarta novos truques para velhos
companheiros unificação de tarefa um
produto ou serviço que você tenha
utilidade e você unifica essa uma outra
tarefa para dentro dele algo que você
jamais imaginou que estivesse com
relacionada ao jogo para buscar algo na
internet e vejo que o brasileiro é muito
criativo
alguém quer fazer um churrasco por
exemplo em casa e não tem churrasqueiro
faltou gás e ele tem essa idéia
inovadora de unificar pagar algo que ele
não imaginava que servir serviria para
fazer um churrasco e ele faz um
churrasco com ferro de passar roupas
a idéia é maravilhosa é só em da água
mas é no japão descobriu se por milhares
de anos de pesquisa que o homem olha
para a pena de mulher
foi uma pesquisa realmente muito árdua e
com base nesse dado científico de vários
de anos e milenar milenar
eles começaram a perceber que a
conversão de homem que olhava apenas a
mulher era muito maior do que qualquer
outro lugar que eles pudessem fazer
publicidade e no japão
hoje é possível ver mulheres carregando
essas digamos que tatuagens temporárias
para fazer publicidade de filmes
revistas masculinas e afins
dentro desse mesmo conceito com uma
pegada é de produto mais vendável tem a
a sancionar disse que é uma empresa de
mochilas nas mochilas mais um dos times
mais famosos do mundo e eles queriam
entrar no mercado de mochila pra escola
eles vêm as malas de diversas maneiras
no mundo inteiro é a número um no mundo
e aí qual é o problema de vender
mochilas não tinha expertise nenhuma
nesse mercado tinham várias outras
empresas querendo entrar e competir e
ter uma idéia fantástica vamos unificar
as tarefas
vamos pegar algo que antes não foi
imaginado para uma mochila e resolver um
problema de novo a necessidade é a mãe
da inovação o que eles pensaram qual o
principal problema de utilizar uma
mochila
o peso das mochilas são extremamente
pesadas que eles pensaram bem se pensar
na base de multiplicação num
multiplicador uma mochila colocaria
rodinhas né e você não teria mais
problema com o peso
você apenas carregar a mochila com sua
mão que acontece em muitos casos com as
crianças mas eles foram muito além
eles queriam dar um atributo dentro da
mochila que trouxesse a inovação nunca
vista antes em que foi o que eles
fizeram
eles colocaram pontos de shiatsu na
mochila
então quanto mais peso você põe na
mochila mas sensação de prazer
vai ter então vai ser possível quando
você vê alguém andando relaxada se na
rua não é porém uma necessidade
fisiológica
se tiver de mochila é porque
provavelmente ele esteja utilizando a
mochila da funcionária
essa mochila extremamente cara mas
ganhou vários mercados já é possível
encontrar inclusive aqui no brasil
mochila sensacionais que tem essa
sensação de prazer pelos pontos de shazo
a quinta template de correlações
inteligentes dependência de atributo é
quando você gera um atributo que depende
do outro
e aí o exemplo que eu quero trazer para
vocês é do bicho folha que aquele bicho
que que tem na amazônia por exemplo na
amazônia que ele se adapta em sua
coloração
se a gente pegar essa idéia da natureza
e trazer essa ideia para a nossa
realidade de inovação
a gente vai ver que ele tem várias
funções a funcionabilidade por exemplo
quem nunca se queimou pegando uma xícara
de café ou algo quente
imagine se a gente tirar esse bicho
folha esse aprendizado de adaptação e
aplicar um produto onde o próprio a
própria xícara ou caneca nos informa a
sua tonalidade se está quente ou se está
gelada ou afins em termos de temperatura
o segundo leite que nunca cheirou leite
colocou leite um pouquinho na boca para
saber se ele está fazendo isso é
totalmente desnecessário
e se o leite mudar de coala dizer que
foi chegando próximo a sua data de
expirar em um caso fantástico na rede de
supermercados tesco que é uma rede do
reino unido que eles queriam entrar na
coreia do sul eles descobriram uma coisa
fantástica a necessidade é a mãe
a inovação a coreia do sul tem sua
população a segunda população que mais
trabalha no mundo recebendo isso eles
notaram obviamente que essas pessoas não
têm tempo então foi o que eles fizeram
onde é que elas passam a maior parte do
seu tempo na estação de metrô
eles colocaram adesivos nas estações de
metrô com que a codhes aqueles códigos
qr que a faz a leitura pelo céu
lá que você consegue comprar o produto
da própria estação por essa leitura de
código
eles enviam automaticamente suas compras
para sua casa
então você vai trabalhar passa no metrô
faz a compra no próprio vetores metrô
esses adesivos que ficam iguais às
prateleiras
quando você chega em casa no final do
dia você tem seus produtos à disposição
moral da história
luca pensem fora da caixa que pensar
fora da caixa
pensa em criação se você quer inovar
existem várias templates como eu acabei
de mostrar que torna esse sistema de
inovação muito mais prático o macaco me
falou uma vez uma coisa fantástica
eu não preciso ficar criando tentando
criar músicas diferentes
o meu primeiro sucesso - segundo sucesso
na verdade são template quando eu vi que
as pessoas gostavam daquela música
quando eu vi que aquela música foi um
sucesso nas músicas mais regravadas do
mundo
eu só peguei a mesma base a mesma tem
player
eu multiplicaria ela eu transformei a
mesma música em uma outra música eu
inovei é um modelo a música eu mudei
alguns tons mas a base dela a template é
da mesma música
então pra inovar a gente precisa pensar
dentro da caixa
obrigado e boa tarde